really speaking, how successful is rife for colon cancer? It's very successful for colon cancer.
There's not very many cancers that we haven't seen literally miracles with the rife
machine. But the truth is, is that you don't see miracles with the rife machine with every person
regardless of what cancer it is. But I can't think of one cancer that I would say, oh,
rife just doesn't work for that. Because we have had people, you know, I've been doing this
a long time and we've treated just about every cancer you could think of, even rare ones. And
we've seen miracles with all of them. So, but certainly, it certainly doesn't work for everybody.
It's not a magic weapon for cancer. Though, again, I've said over and over, I wouldn't try
to treat cancer without it. But yeah, certainly if I had cancer, if I had colon cancer, any cancer,
I'd be using the rife.